'R
VOTINGAWNSMPLIEDPL
ANINCOCA-COLA, TOO.
WHAT I AM SAYING HERE IS THIS IA
>> YETE HYPOCRY IScCONNELL.
HE SAID IN 2012.
HARASSMECRG DEFENSES DSELVES OUE
THEIR OWN GOVERNMENT SIMPLY
NOT LIKE THESAGOVE
NELL DOES NOT AGE THEY ARE ADVO
AND HE'S THE MOST SENIOR AN.
HE CERTAIN A P T
GO
WHEN HE E TH IT IS
OURA .
O YO OF WH DOING HER I T
EX H.
>>cC WHETH COMPANIES SHOULD GIVO
POLITICAL DONATIERT IN A THAN
I SAID IT, DAN.LET ME
T TALKING ABT
TIS.
CIB
SIDES AND THAT'SE AND LEGAL
APPROPRIATE, I
CORPORATIO S NOT ON BLEM WHEN
DE.>> YEAH, THAT'S WHAT IAP DANY
I DNLIZE Y'ALLES ARE
AS AND STILL IS ATHE TIP
OF THE SPEF  ONE VOCATE FOR CITT
ERICA BEINLOWED
TONDIMITEDUMONEY CAMPAE ARGUMEN
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
AND BE AE
IT ID TONDERSTAND T AND TH
DON'T HAVE SAME RI
SPEAK OU FOR
EIN COMPANY  THIS
AMENDMEN IDING AS A  MAKE
DON'T LIKE THIS NEW GEGIA
RESTRICTIVE SO
WE'LL MOVE.
CORPORATIONS PE
>>AK-- T COMES T
MONEY BUTOIR O
VIEW>> D
>> YES.
>> THIS JUSTNED.YOU HA PRESIDERA
STSLREPUBLICAN GN KEMP, 'ST THE.
SAYS "KEMP ALSD OTHE RADICA W
>>RUD ISE DOING BY MAKING
H P>>LL GOT T KIND OF ANGUAGE AN
CIR WITH TN
EORGIA.UMP IS TP A I THINK THISE
F FOVOEORGIAD
STUFF AND SHLD HAVE ENROUGH.
IN AND RELEVANT AND IT
IS REALLGO ND ECONOMIC HARM IN
GEORGIA THE WAY I SEE IT.
KENTA ANNO BOYCOTTD
T REAL, I AM SUR
WOULD AGREE WITH ME EMENT
O KE GOVERNO
Y NE
REPUBLICANS WITH THIS LAW
SPISP FO PERSONA